bien mes chers amis je voudrais
évidemment salué notre président nicolas
merci d'être avec nous évidemment vous
plaît le saluer un sénateur et non des
moindres jean pierre raffarin merci jean
pierre d'être avec nous et puis tous les
têtes de liste aux régionales
très rapidement je voudrais vous dire
vous l'avez sans doute remarqué que
l'imagination des socialistes est un
puits sans fond on pensait avoir tout
connu avoir tout vu en fait nous avions
rien vu il y avait eu leonarda on a eu
des ratés les volte face
les échecs mais alors cette semaine ça a
été un feu d'artifice ça a été un
festival et vous me permettrez de rendre
hommage à deux femmes d'abord à lucette
c'est pas lui cette c'est pas lui c'est
qu'il faut siffler avec lucette françois
hollande inventé le peuple potemkine le
peuple virtuel avec lucette
françois hollande a donné un visage le
visage du mépris de la gauche du mat du
mépris du parti socialiste pour les
classes populaires
voilà pour moi ce que représente lucette
et puis je voudrais aussi rendre un
hommage mais le terme est sans doute mal
choisi à une autre femme elle s'appelle
myriam meriane c'est une autre figure
plutôt s'étale notre symbole le symbole
d'une gauche et d'un président de la
république qui choisit le casting la
communication dès lors qu'il s'agit de
choisir le ministre du travail alors que
le chômage c'est le cancer de la société
française
alors que le chômage devrait être la
grande cause nationale et on cède à la
politique politicienne
on s'aide au casting et on choisit
l'incompétence plutôt qu'un compétences
c'est absolument lamentable et entre les
deux entre lucette et myriam vous avez
eu du festival vous avez eu monsieur
eckert pour la première fois sous la
vème république un ministre du budget
qui s'adresse aux français pour leur
dire surtout ne payez pas d'impôts
évidemment ces sympathiques
vous avez eu aussi après la mini des
affaires sociales qui veut faire la
poche des handicapés c'est incroyable
les socialistes pour y penser
et vous avez la brave maryse lebranchu
qu'est une fois qu'elle avait inscrite
dans le projet de loi de finances son
projet de réforme pour les subventions
collectivités qui revient en arrière
parce que le premier ministre le lui a
demandé
tout ça est absolument lamentable
évidemment c'est un symbole le symbole
voyez c'est la france qui tombe le
symbole c'est la fonction présidentielle
qui est désormais atteinte dans son
coeur
et pour paraphraser camus désormais
françois hollande est devenu une machine
à désespérer et exaspérer les français
alors oui les élections oui oui les
élections régionales du cici du 13
décembre prochain ce sera une occasion
d'adresser à françois hollande et à son
gouvernement et aux socialistes un
carton rouge
évidemment ces élections ont une
dimension nationale
évidemment qui a choisi la date le 6 et
le 13 décembre la plus mauvaise toutes
les dates là où on risque d'avoir une
abstention maximale
là où on aura les français dont l'esprit
aura basculé dans les fêtes de noël
françois hollande son gouvernement
forcément y aura la coop 21 et avec
l'aco 21
vous savez très bien que il pense que
les reports de voix que les fusions
entre les listes socialistes et les
listes écologiques seront plus faciles
vous avez là tout françois hollande prêt
à sacrifier l'intérêt national a ses
petites manoeuvres politiciennes
bien sûr ces élections régionales ont
une dimension nationale
y'a pas des bons socialistes dans nos
régions et des socialistes critiquable
au niveau national c'est exactement les
mêmes avec les mêmes méthodes les mêmes
visions et les mêmes résultats
les mêmes méthodes dans ma région il
avait ouvert une ambassade tenez vous
bien au burundi à bujumbura
je peux vous dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
d'entreprises pme des pays de la loire
qui exportent à bujumbura
ils ont embauché depuis dix ans un
fonctionnaire tous les quinze jours
et pire et pire ils les ont double nez
avec des commissaires politiques comme
du bon vieux temps de l'urss
ils sont extraordinaires les socialistes
toujours plus de dépenses publiques
alors évidemment c'est toujours plus un
ponot chez nous mais chers collègues
tête de liste on a le record la palme
d'or mon cher philippe la palme d'or
pour l'augmentation de la fiscalité sur
les cartes grises sur le mandat le
dernier mandat et la dette explose et
forcément quand vous dépensez vous fait
exploser la dette
donc bien sûr que les élections
régionales ce sera l'occasion de
sanctionner les socialistes
les mêmes méthodes mais en même temps
les mêmes échecs toujours plus de jeunes
au chômage
toujours plus de jeunes décrocheurs
toujours plus de chômeurs évidemment
dans nos régions et toujours -
d'apprentis alors que moi ma région
longtemps a été même 2 1 devant la
région alsace la première de toutes les
régions
c'était il ya bien longtemps pour
l'apprentissage 4 lille apprentis de
moins en sept ans alors voilà ils ont
trouvé une arme nucléaire
pendant les régionales pour la campagne
l'arme nucléaire
ces deux promettent la gratuité sur les
transports scolaires extraordinaire de
nouveautés une promesse 100% socialiste
évidemment demain on rase gratis
une promesse 100% démagogique comment
penser que certains aient la gratuité
sont que tout le monde paye encore plus
de fiscalité est évidemment aussi une
promesse 100% irresponsable alors il se
transforme en père noël à quelques
semaines de noël mais il voudrait nous
transformer nous il nous désigne comme
les pères fouettards la gauche n'a pas
changé c'est les mêmes échecs mais c'est
en même temps toujours la même bonne
conscience le même monopole vous savez
qui leur permet de désigner le camp du
bien et le camp du mal alors nous
forcément puisqu'ils sont à bout
d'arguments on est le camp du mal on est
la droite dure et vous savez pour eux ce
que c'est que la droite dure la droite
dure c'est ceux à qui on est et on
étiquette offrons cette étiquette parce
que on ne veut pas se taire et ne nous
tairons pas nous dirons aux français la
vérité
évidemment et nous disons la vérité la
vérité sur notre dame des landes est le
symbole de l'affaissement de l'autorité
de l'état
le centre ville de nantes saccagé à deux
reprises une brigade de gendarmerie
attaqué une voiture de gendarmerie
attaqué et brûlé par un commando masqué
un camion son chauffeur qui se perd sur
une route départementale qui a été
privatisé le chauffeur arrêté parce
qu'il ya un checkpoint et on n'est pas
damas on n'est pas me saoule
on est en loire atlantique le chauffeur
s'enfuit son camion et pillé
voilà la loire atlantique alors bien sûr
manuel valls
avec ses airs de matador que l'on
connaît a promis le redémarrage des
travaux
simplement je vous dis y'a pas une
entreprise privée qui fera les travaux
aussi au préalable la loi n'est pas
respectée
si au préalable c'est ultra violent ne
dégage pas il faut bien sûr évacuer
notre dame des landes
parce que c'est un territoires perdus de
la république et nous ne voulons pas du
ter non plus sur un fléau qu'il en ma
région parce que ma région pays de la
loire et malheureusement celle qui de
toutes les autres régions est la plus
touchée par les addictions la drogue
l'alcoolisme
parlez-en par les ans la gauche vous
aider la gauche en offusque la gauche ni
évidemment ils sont alliés avec les
écolos qui n'ont jamais rien fait
pousser de leur vie sauf sauf du
cannabis sur leur balcon
et bien moi je ne veux pas me laver les
mains parce que la drogue les addictions
c'est la dépendance et l'aliénation
parce que c'est un drame pour des
milliers de jeunes pour des milliers de
familles et nous allons lancer je sais
aussi que mes collègues ils sont à la
tête de liste des différentes régions le
front un grand plan de lutte contre la
drogue
je vais vous dire pour conclure j'ai une
conviction c'est que le laxisme
ça n'est jamais la solution le laxisme
c'est une erreur politique
le laxisme c'est une formidable
injustice est d'abord une injustice pour
les jeunes parce que lorsque l'on dit
aux jeunes qu'ils n'ont que des droits
qu'ils n'ont aucun de voix on est trop
pour leur ment et on les empêche de
grandir
évidemment on les condamne à perpétuité
on les condamne à perpétuité à
l'assistanat c'est à dire à la
dépendance au moment où on devrait
grandir et envisager l'avenir de façon
libre et au fond indépendante voilà ce
que nous ferons nous allons relancer
aussi les bourses pour le mérite pour
les bacheliers début familles modestes
bien évidemment et pour les décrocheurs
pour tous ces jeunes qui sont en
souffrance
nous leur dirons la région te tend la
main à une condition pas d'assistanat
à une condition nous allons aider tu
signes un contrat année un contrat
d'efforts individuels
on va t'aider tu dois passer le permis
de conduire ça coûte de l'argent
on va financer mais en contrepartie tu
t'engages tu bosses ça n'était pour une
association pour une autre entreprise
voilà mes chers mes chers amis il faut
vous mobiliser il n'y aura pas
d'alternance en 2010 7,6 au mois de
décembre 2015
nous ne remportons pas de grandes
victoires régionales entre le front
national et le parti des bonimenteurs
télé partie des yaka fokon et le parti
socialiste et le parti de l'échec
nous devons nous les républicains dans
l'union avec nos amis centristes
représentées pour les français une
espérance vivent nos régions françaises
vivent les républicains et par dessus
tout vive la france